the city of Tokyo is built around and
over rivers when you travel around here
it is striking just how often you cross
water and from up above
you can see this whole area is flat
low-lying coastal land some parts of
Tokyo even set below sea level they've
sunk because of decades of pumping out
groundwater for two and a half million
people in those low-lying areas are
protected by a network of floodgates and
Ageing levees which will be fine unless
sea levels rise
but even inland a huge part of this mega
city is built in river basins and flood
plains and as the climate breaks down
rainstorms here are getting more intense
and more frequent if you want to prevent
River flooding or drain neighborhoods
that are starting to flood where do you
put the water if you pump it out of that
neighborhood you're likely just moving
the flood next door the best plan would
in theory would be to pump the
floodwater all the way to the ocean
or at least to a tidal river that can
deal with it but for that you would need
tunnels and buffer tanks on almost
unimaginable scale now despite what some
breathless blog posts might claim the
whole metropolis doesn't have that but
there is one place about an hour north
of the center of Tokyo that does
this is the metropolitan area outer
underground discharge channel or at
least one part of it the holding tank it
is almost impossible to convey the scale
of this on camera no chicken you can't
say well she was hanging up now gotta
tell you cheeky Noddy must stay patella
my sister got the kid of mine into it a
walk
it also Taylor muckerman cousin Cara
kozhukattai
hello hang this into your pocket or
equal to our most common chicken in our
era two short enemies Oh Chicago force
we don't need rodeo she must a Chicago
narrow okie nakawara
a token horny - any mosque if you touch
you for a Tony a naka River start to
flood this is where the water will drain
- actually where the water is sort of
still draining - there was a massive
rainstorm about two days ago and there
is still water in the system
I'm not allowed down on the floor just
in case the key to mine Wow cheesy music
you know it's a union and neek according
monster tell you who they were she's
amazing Roxanna and I hate I don't know
she's amazing he got on this couch I
dunno
she took a digital code Tony OTT remain
secure Donna journey victory here at
coca-cola Nariman stuff
we also named Khan nanika o hadouken o
Stamos Oh Sarah needs camasta wa hitotsu
Kanye's mizuyama come we must a
component HT II don't wanna meet Oaxaca
- they must know they eat pie dinero to
your audit agency your motif was it
shows its openness autonomous even take
any missile permit a chimera river Ganga
only else pushed it kind of means Oaxaca
de Soto you say oh she must know de this
tank and the kilometers of tunnels and
all the silos that bring water to it
cost nearly a quarter of a trillion yen
there's almost 2 billion US dollars at
the end of the 20th century that was
when the Japanese government was
spending money to finance enormous
infrastructure projects like this to try
and stimulate the economy which for long
term security is great but it took a
national recession to make this happen a
plan like this only works if the
government wants to spend a colossal
amount of money and in the 21st century
there aren't many governments willing to
do that thank you to all the team here
for letting me down in the tank and up
on these catwalks
you can find out more about them and
their work at the link in the
description echo
I goes for a long while